um our first speaker is wen longmu and
uh he's a
phd student here in berkeley advised by
martin wainwright and peter bartlett
works on many aspects of machine
learning
and sampling
and optimization and today's talk is
about higher order management diffusion
thanks centos for the introduction so
i'm winlow today i'm very happy to
present my work on high order landmark
diffusion then accelerated mcnc
algorithm
uh this is don't work with ian ma who's
sitting
supposed to be sitting in this room but
she didn't show up enough
and
my advisors martin winrich peter barkley
and mike jordan
so
um
let's start let me first give some
preliminary results i guess
those discussion would be like familiar
to most of the people in this room but
it is still good to
like go from the very like easy problem
use the algorithm to see really
difficulty lighting and then like
slightly like move to our main theme of
discussion which is our
like high order london algorithm
so
we consider as all the like most of
other talks for today and this week we
consider like a log concave sampling
problem you have a
potential function f
with like beta smooth and mu strongly
convex
and
of course there are a lot of
applications for sampling that's why we
are sitting
there
here
like basic influence and sequential
depletion making and for those problems
the dimension of the space that you are
trying to sample from is usually very
high so that's why we like we are so
interested in like finding
algorithms with uh like slower and lower
dimension dependency and this talk is
also
uh about like getting better and better
dimension dependency for sampling
algorithms
and in particular like for
like reasonable class of uh
like problems we got the like
uh best known dimension dependency
without too many additional assumptions
so uh here's uh what everyone knows this
is just a london diffusion uh you just
uh you just have this stochastic
differential equation and it has another
mild irregularity conditions it is
impossibly converted to the stationary
matter and
you can use standard coupling method
under strong convexity you can use
standard coupling method to show its
quantitative convergence in the
continuous time everything is nice
if you try to discretize that um
know that actually i wrote a relatively
non-standard form of
like describation of the forward euler
method but essentially what you are
doing is
within a small time interval
uh instead of running the original
diffusion process you run a brand new
motion with constant drift
and the drift term is coming from the
initial point
of
this interval and this is a very natural
like
algorithmic idea and this is uh like
analogous to gradient descent in
optimization
and this algorithm has been like
intensively analyzed under different
settings
and
so where does the distribution error for
this algorithm mainly come from
so basically
what you do is you replace this theta t
by theta like k eta by the point as the
initial uh state
and
like the difference between these two
guys is of order root eta d because you
drive it by a d dimensional branch
motion and its fluctuations of a root
eta so
uh this leads to a further ruling
deduction error
uh if you don't assume any other
assumption this is like very classical
work
if you further assume the question of
athlete's lipschitz uh in terms of
operator norm actually you can get
improved results
um
and the nice aspect of this result is
that this result doesn't actually
require the capacity of the potential
function f
so
of course one may ask can we do better
and there are existing works that
improve dimensional dependency which is
london diffusion
and the reason why underlying london
diffusion is better is intuitively it's
it moves the brownian motion part
to the part that does not directly
involve taking the gradient so basically
the brain emotion part of prgr and here
you you basically when you when you want
to take determination you want to take
gradient ff at a discrete point
and you run the curve for theta you want
basically the the path for this
like a different category differential
equation you want the scissor part of
this path to be not that non-smooth
like we know that the branching motion
roughly rusted speaking is like a half
order holder
but if you integrate it once you get to
like basically three halves smoothness
and this helps a lot actually this gives
like root d
uh mixing time for for underdogs
london algorithm
and
i just want to mention that the proof uh
for this for the
like convergence rate for this
continuous time diffusion is also
not that hard you basically you take a
synchronous coupling and you take this
lyapunov function and
you can show that this diagonal function
is decaying at an external rate
and
the reason why i want to talk about this
is because
the idea of construction for a third
order london diffusion is also like
following a similar path and you will
see that
using uh like integration oracle and
uh like third order more complicated
long run diffusion how this thing can
further improve the dimensional
dependency
so
here's the discretized version of the
underdamped london diffusion as we see
what people actually do is simply by
replacing the theta t
with theta k eta hat which is uh
the point again the point has the
initial state of this
and
this differential equation is solvable
with the explicit solution it's just the
oil process
uh jointly in c and r so you if you give
me an initial state and the gradient of
f i can i can directly
write down the like one step transition
kernel is just the gaussian one
and the the reason why this guy gives
like root d by epsilon missing time is
also formulas follows a very intuitive
analysis
so
the theta process as i just just said it
is much more smooth than the theta
process in in the uh like overdumped
london diffusion but you still pay for
some dimension factor here in particular
you run within like a eta time interval
and this rt process is like it's a just
a generic
vector in this space and you can think
of it as something like this
distribution like gaussian like or sub
gaussian in either direction
and this thing has uh
like norm bonded by also root d
and
then you substitute it into this process
and you will show that the black step
you can see that one step digitalization
error for this r process is of order eta
square times root d
and that means the digitalization error
for the r process itself is eta times
root d
sorry there's a there's a typo this
should be theta t hat minus theta t
uh
and in the end you get the
digitalization error for the entire
process is over eta times root d this
just comes
this this eta times root d no longer
comes from the very viral oscillation of
the brain emotion it comes from a very
well controlled process
it's just
you have you have a like a
generic like gaussian type gaussian like
vector in this r-dimensional space in
this dimensional space
and
you try to integrate that and you use
the starting initial point to
approximate this integral and this
naturally leads to eta times root d
digitalization error if you take either
if you take your step size to be either
there's
nothing like much more we can do here
and
after this works there are also some
some follow-up works on like several
different directions
uh
so as i just said for long-range
diffusion for the analgesic long-run
diffusion uh basically you have to pay
for
a linear in dimension
and uh there are some uh
like improvements in terms of gibson
dependency but uh the best known
dependency on dimensions uh
it's linear unless you assume some like
more unrealistic
like assumptions that could tie further
hide the dimension dependency
for
under that long run algorithm under the
same set of assumptions
you can get like a root d
dimension dependency and there is uh
a further improvement by rochi who is
also sitting in this room which gives
you like youtube answers this is based
on very smart idea of taking a random
missed point instead of just the initial
point or just
the mu point of the integral
but
it's just hard to further improve this
dimension dependency along this
direction
and there's the hamiltonian monte carlo
which gives you
results that are in the form similar
form as the endodontic london diffusion
which is reasonable
and also there's the
work by centos and coarsers which
uh impose like stronger assumptions on
the physically they consider like a
generalized linear model
where each data is
the data somehow mutually incoherent
by incoherence basically it means that
the inner product between two data
points are bounded by a constant so
basically the data are like
pointing to very different directions so
if you have two data points that are
very close then this assumption gets
break down
so
as you see this works although
like gas improvement in certain regimes
this is
this assumption is generally very strong
and
this our work
further improve the dimension
dependencies due to the band force
under an integration oracle
i will explain what the integration
article is uh in the next section so for
practical for uh the takeaway is that
for most practical algorithms you can
afford for most the practical
application models are like the problems
encountered in whatever like exploration
constant sampling
most log concave distributions satisfy
this kind of integration article a nice
example is again the
like generalized linear model or we call
it a read separable functions i will
explain this in the next section
so
uh let's continue the discussion about
can i ask about the previous slide yeah
so what did what class of functions are
the
last three rows for what assumptions
would you make okay so
the assumption the precise assumption we
are making is that uh
so you take a function and take its
gradient and for any line segment you
just need a street line segment uh you
have explicit formula for computing the
integral of its gradient along this line
segment
and this is satisfied for example by
like generalized linear motor for
example if you consider bayesian logical
regression even with this regular it's
regularization term and it's
others and some other stuff because
for your models uh for each data point
it is usually a one-dimensional function
that you really need to integrate
and you just integrate this
one-dimensional function using some
explicit formulas and some just
one-dimensional integration techniques
and you combine them some some
sum them up to to get the the
like
the the integration oracle for the
physical empirical gradient function
that you are you're caring about
so you don't need convexity oh you need
convexity you need strongly complexity
and smooth but you the important aspect
of this class of assumption is that it
doesn't need anything about
individual functions so you you need the
average function to be or the summation
to be strongly complex and smooth
but you don't need anything about you
don't need them they're norms if you
found it you don't need them to be
incoherent you don't need any like
individual lipsticks or whatever
so just to wrap up so there is a
dependence on kappa that's not shown
here right yeah yeah i'm i'm hiding yeah
that's a good point i'm hiding i'm
hiding all the dependency on kappa yes
so basically you can think of copper as
a constant and we are just trying to
improve the dimension dimension
dependency and this is a very
interesting future direction to further
improve the copper dependence i think
the kabbalah definitely
it's not necessarily due to our
algorithm i think it tends to believe is
due to our analysis i think the the
topic dependency in our paper is not
tight and we actually we didn't like
work very hard to get it optimal
yeah that's uh that's that's a good
point i have to mention that
okay so let's continue the discussion
about uh the difficulties with uh
describation
so we know that describation of for
example if you want to compute some
some integral the discussion is
something well studied and
like why is it so difficult in height
for this high dimensional sampling
problem
well we know that for
for example for one dimensional low
dimensional
description problems you can if you're
just
solving a vitamin ode for example
then you can you have a lot of methods
like linear multi-step methods longer
cool time as a collocation method and
this method essentially is taking a few
like interpolation points and try to
approximate this integral using some
lagrangian polynomial or whatever and
sometimes you also need to solve the
fixed point equation associated to this
futurization method
and if you get k like interpolation
points usually you can get eta to the
roughly speaking it has the key
utilization error which is uh very small
and which is very desirable
so
why is it so difficult the problem there
are a lot of things that breaks down in
high dimensional problems and
equalization is one of them
uh the problem with describing
discretizing this high dimensional
integral is that
as we just said
the the difference between the point is
very evaluates the visualization point
where you try to compute the
digitalization and the actual process
actual
like point that this this differential
equation is uh generated if the
difference between them is of all the
eta times root d
like no matter how large order
digitalization
matter you use you get eta times rule d
to the power of k
and this does improve the epsilon
dependence in your final mixing time but
if you want to get to
uh
like
if you want to get better dimension
dependency it doesn't help and actually
like no matter how many orders of
smoothness you have in and you always
get
like basically a ud dimension dependency
and that's why actually in centos work
uh we need this kind of it is like an
iron infinitive version of the tensor
prison arm bond and
it helps the discrimination a lot and
uh it is uh
this is a great work but uh i mean it is
uh
this assumption is relatively
restrictive and
uh that's not that it's not satisfied by
many models
so can we do something better so it
seems like all the difficulty lies in
computing this kind of integral so what
if i give you an integration oracle we
know that for many practical problems
the form of the problem actually gives
you the possibility of computing
integration directly so what if i give
you
a simplest form of integration article
which is
like
basically
if i if i give you the
uh
oracle for computing an integration of
the gradient of function along any line
segment
can we use this oracle to get a better
sampling algorithm
so the idea is that we know that this
if theta really follows this sde then
the path for theta is actually a
like a curve very like difficult to
control
stuff but what if we just
replace we just take a one like simple
fold all the steps
to
to take a to to restrict it to a
straight line segment and integrate
allow these grease line segments using
this integration oracle and use this
oracle's x axis to further incorporate
it into our sampling algorithm to
digest the possibility possibility of
like improved sampling algorithm
so this
uh gives rise to two questions first is
under what kind of assumptions can we
explicitly compute this integral this is
of course a question
and the second question is
even if you are able to compute this
integral explicitly but how can you
incorporate it into the stochastic
differential equation that you are
trying to solve and actually give you a
better sampling algorithm
so first first question the answer is
relatively simple
uh essentially
in order to be able to compute this type
of integration
uh
one example is uh you can you can just
like take you can just assume the
function to be of read separable form
you can think of it like a generalized
linear model like logistical version
actually
i i cannot think of actually i cannot
think of a practical like log concave
sampling problem that appears in visual
influence that does not satisfy this
form
and if your function after given this
form then you are actually integrating a
by-dimensional you are integrating by
dimensional derivative
and
you can just solve the integration
problem using fundamental theorems
calculus and this is just a high school
calculation problem and gives you this
formula
and it is important to know that
to note that our result only requires
uh
the availability of such integration
oracle so if your function is written in
this form i don't care like
whether the individual ai has a large
norm or they are mutually coherent or
whatever i just require this function to
be able to give this integration
uh like formula integration oracle and
it has to be strongly complex sentences
so the second question is
harder and it's a very subtle problem if
you are trying to utilize the first
tribe of course we have a like
underdamped laundry distribution and we
want to utilize underlying rent
diffusion
but unfortunately this doesn't work
the reason is if you want to compute the
r process for the android laundry
diffusion our process is auxiliary
variable in underdamped
and it gets the two terms actually mixed
together and you cannot directly
separate them the first term is the
integration oracle which which is just
an integration but the second term
involves the past
the entire past and in the middle you
still
have this integration here
and
like using a single integration article
you cannot compute this so this although
i can write down the formula this is not
something that we can we can really
compute using the integration of oracle
so
if you really want to get a faster
sampling algorithm
we may want to separate the part where
you integrate to the grid and the f
and the part where you run this oil
process and inject this brand emotion
so that give rises to the second idea
which is the high order
uh london diffusion
so
uh
under that london diffusion is not the
only uh like version of
high order london diffusion
there's
like a sequence of works by ian
which gives a complete recipe of this
kind of
diffusion process that gives the correct
station distribution
so essentially you can augment your
state space into like
the
underdamped argument your state space
into 2d dimension but you can augment
into three dimensions 3d dimension of 40
dimensional
and
as long as the matrix pair d and q
satisfy this assumption it gives you the
right statement distribution
so
and the principle for defining such
like diffusion process is that first we
want the d
to be
like less non-zero interest as possible
because
like if if if d process has a lot of
nonlinear interest then
then you get injected with more noise
and this uh
this noise can
this noise can make the path less smooth
and harder to describe
and second principle is that
you run this cube process q process it's
like a transport part of the equation
and you want this cube process to
be able to separate the part where you
compute the integral of the binding
motion and the part of your computer
integrals
of the gradient
and based on these two principles we can
design this diffusion process this is a
3d dimensional
uh
like diffusion for d dimensional
sampling
so essentially
this theta depends on this p process but
for people and p processes uh like to
compute p process you need to compute
the integrals or gradients of f
but this p process does not have any
branching motion directly
injected into this process it depends on
brand emotion through this r process
and in such way we separate the gradient
part and the branding part of the of
this process and this gives the
possibility of making use of this
integration article and
building like a sample algorithm with
better dimension dependency
and of course if we constructed such
process the first thing we should do is
to verify that this thing actually
converges exponentially fast
unfortunately this is true and the way
we do that is uh
like recall that for for
underdamped language diffusion we can
construct a reactional function and show
that lyapunov function is exponentially
king
and we do the same thing for the
high-order london distribution and it
gives you a little bit more complicated
reactional function
and uh
but fortunately we can we can show uh i
have as i said we don't really
like
try very hard to get the optimal
dependency on the condition number so it
is possible that uh the the optimal
function we are constructing is very
very sub-optimal and using a better
reaction function construction
we may be able to improve the condition
number dependency a lot for this problem
and the construction idea how do we get
this construction idea comes from like
very classical theory of
linear dynamical system basically we
borrow ideas from lyapunov's stability
criteria and
solve this matrix inequality
so
now we have a
nice diffusion process with very smooth
paths and the integral part and
part got separated and it remains to
really decrease that and
get a faster sampling algorithm
so here's a like
informal statement of our theorem
so basically uh as i just said if your
function satisfies such nice things with
condition number bounded by a constant
and there exists a differentialization
scheme of the
uh
third order london diffusion that i just
described
such that if you take that size to be
basically
sorry this should be epsilon to the one
half instead of each one to the minus
one half if you take step size to be
equal
to the one half d to the minus one
fourth
you get this
like d to the 1 4 mix in time
and
this is the iteration complexity of
the algorithm and it's natural to ask
what is the per iteration complexity
and for each iteration
we invoke one integration oracle
as i explained and some additional
calculations just like adding things
together and generating the mineral
branding motion and add it to the to the
uterus and all these things are fixable
between od time
so the pro iteration cost is as cheap as
computing the gradient as long as your
function satisfies the next form
okay so that's how we describe that oh
by the way this discoloration scheme is
completely explicit which means that you
don't need to solve any fixed point
equation to to compute the one step
update you just need to i can just
explicitly write down a matrix
that you based on this matrix you can
just update your iterate and get what
you want
so
recall that this is our third order
dynamics
and the hard part lies in p and we want
to so this p involves both the gradient
which is the hard which is hard to
integrate
and
something that
that depends on the brain emotion but it
does not directly depend on the brain
motion
so
why don't we first construct some cause
approximation to the diffusion process
within this small time interval for this
theta process and our process
so let's leave to the first stage of our
digitalization argument
um
so
here
like the child is
like p of basically theta p and r of uh
like k eta with the tudor on top means
the last step means the output of the
last step
so
our algorithm is basically update from
the cube to the from
kilda's
time k eta to the time like k plus 1
times eta
and height
all the
things with hatch
are like some auxiliary process which
which is beneficial conceptually for the
construction of this digitalization
scheme but not really used in our
algorithm
so
let's first
that's what we do first we constructed
two hats
uh the two hats are the
cause approximation for the
uh
path of the diffusion process
and of course uh by the
like again you are integrating this
manual vector and
the utilization error here is of other
ether times root d
for
like this step and the next step for
this
like cross approximation
here's a very simple
like animation for that so you can see
that basically for each for for theta
hatch process you just
you just move along a line segment
there's no branch motion injected to
that and there's nothing non-linear
happening
and for this architect just wrong with
the oil process
which is explicitly solvable as we just
discussed
so
uh
we've got this thing
in hand and how do we make use of that
that's the key step that's the second
stage of
our construction which is uh to make use
of this cause approximation for theta
hat and zeta has an r hat to construct
some approximation for the
p process in this diffusion
and the way we do that so we construct
both p children and p hat
[Music]
so actually uh this for these two
processes the endpoints are the same
uh as you can just see the input if you
just integrate the first process you'll
see easily see that the endpoints are
the same
and
actually algorithmically we only use the
endpoint of p k plus p of k plus one q
that and this thing is computable
through an integration oracle
so what if what do we do is that we can
conditionally all the information up to
time k eta
you first involve invoke the integration
oracle
and compute the integral along a
deterministic line segment know that
this line segment has to be
deterministic we cannot support any like
integration oracle unless the stochastic
path
and
then
given this we use this to compute this
audio process everything is everything
else is a joint oil process we make use
of this and compute the joint oil
process
and uh
so this this p
p of two p two d of k plus one is
directly integrable uh using using the
information given to us
and the important thing is that uh
although the
the
amount of move within this utah time is
still over gita times root d
but if you try to align this p hat
process and p to the process their
difference is over the eta square times
root d and that's why like from very
very high level reasoning that's why
like it is possible to get like d to the
one fourth desperation error
so here's what we are actually doing in
this step
so
this is just a conceptual construction
this is the not the way we really run
the algorithm the very really around the
algorithm is that we
like compute all the explicit constants
and just
do some matrix multiplication
uh
a three by three matrix multiplication
so
we suppose we are given the path for
theta hat and r hat which is the line
segment and the oil process
and this p p q and p hat are just
constructed by tracing the path tracing
the both paths
and uh
integrating
and in the end they should end at the
same endpoint because the integral
involved in p uh in p p hat is just
an average version of the integral
involved in p two there
here's the last state of our
construction so basically
this part
gives you the final approximation for
theta tilde and r tilde in the last step
and the way we do that is we make use of
the p hat process
we know that p cubed is something we
have conceptually in man she has what we
really use in the construction
and
but they are not too different as i just
said there are different
bonded of other eta square times root d
and by integrating this p hat process
you get a like final approximation for
the path of theta and final
approximation for r
and
this thing
is the
the the initial point that you use in
the construction of the next user is
and
it is important to note that
if you try to align the tilde and tutors
and tests at the same time point their
differences always of other eta square
times root d instead of eta times root d
and this gives the final
like eta times square root d final
digitalization error bound
so
the way we
do the last step
is as you can see
so basically we track the
so p q then p hat tracks the move of the
theta to the theta
and
further like cesar children our cuda
tracks move a p hat
and
everything is explicitly solvable using
the integral integration article and
don't like 5d dimensional oil process
which can be explicitly computed
and this gives the final result
so here's the main takeaways
as i just said we basically make use of
this special structure that allows for
this integration oracle and they use
high order london diffusion to get a
faster
high
sampling algorithm which due to the
rainforest
uh mixing time
um
it is
relatively easy to implement
this is a bit hard for algorithm
designers because we really do a lot of
manual calculations to compute all the
constants in the in the updated equation
but it's very easy to implement
and
there are a lot of open questions if you
want to pursue further
research on this line
um
first
it is natural to ask
like third order alignment diffusion
give you like usual and first if you do
like fourth order fifth order can we do
something even better
and my conductor is that it requires the
integration oracle along a like
polynomial curve instead of a line
segment so you you can think of
like some some higher order polynomial
and it will further improve the
dimension dependency for sampling
algorithm
and actually ei is going to present a
work which partially solves this problem
by using a different approach and they
are based on
uh
strictly stronger assumptions so it's
direct not direct does not directly
solves this open problem
this problem is still open and the
integration article is not something
specific for sampling i suspect it could
be also useful for certain scenarios in
optimization or depriving like
like od or pds
and also
like
it is still not sure
if you don't have this integration
article there are some things that you
can do to
actually improve the dimension
dependency using only the gradient arc
okay that's all for my talk
thank you
yes
so there have been other third order
algorithms presented in the past for
example
thermostats and so on is there any any
connection or those are those
improvements somehow can be explained
with your theory i think the motivation
for the construction are like somewhat
orthogonal because we
we use this for particular reason of
high dimensional digitalization and to
make the
path that you want to integrate
much much smoother but it will be
interesting to see if our analysis
technique or something can have some
connection to them
yeah
yeah okay
so what we found in practice is that
for some of that kind of method it is
also third order the the benefit is that
it controls the cost gradient where you
have a staccato gradient query um so
it's yeah it's really orthogonal to our
work
questions
yes
this one
so i guess i'm just confused like what
in what sense is this this an oracle
like what is the
um actual computational step that this
is um substituting for so so
it's like if your function is really
given by this form
then i just give you this formula to
compute the integration this is exact i
see yeah i mean for there could be other
functions where the numerical
integration along the line segment
happens to be easy and our analysis also
applies to such problems
thank you
that's thank tank again
[Applause]